fortnite season five changed everything
we know about the island the law
and the legend who is jonesy a little
time has passed since the season began
and one thing has been playing on my
mind who was jonty talking to
on the phone in today's video we're
going to tell you who i think
it is and i'll also prove it too so sit
your butt down for 10 minutes slap code
adamaru in the store for more story
theories like this
and let's dive into it agent jones the
imagined order
and the woman calling the shots
[Music]
so much happened at the start of season
five and the end of season four
that some things went unnoticed just in
case you need a refresher
here's the conversation between johnsy
and his boss
they did it we're still here yeah but
the zero point is exposed you have to go
in
oh come on last thing we need's another
snapshot of me inside the loop
no the last thing we need is someone
escaping the loop
you need to get in there and fix it
understood ma'am i'm on it
and do not draw the attention of the
seven jones
wow so much to unpack well today our job
is to uncover her identity
and here it is i believe the head of the
imagined order
is ramirez
do some watching this will make
everything click into place
but others will not have the same
opinion so i prepared something
here's the evidence let's see if i can
convince you by the end of the video
my first piece of research led me back
way back
back to a time before fortnite island
back to a time of saving the world
a few trailers dropped for the game and
in the early release we met
a bot named ray have you ever considered
fighting the forces of evil
because we really need a commander and i
think you've got what it takes
[Music]
it's a really annoying bot so i won't
dwell here
in the opening cut scene rey tells us
our place in the team as a commander
and our first character is ramirez and
then it happens
ramirez speaks ray if you can hear me
now would be a great time to hurry up
what's a firepower situation
let's compare the two voices no the last
thing we need is someone escaping the
loop
you need to get in there and fix it all
right people let's search this dump and
get out of here asap
and do not draw the attention of the
seven jones
three bears guys who's up for pizza
do you think there's a similarity here
could they be played by the same actress
maybe not but fortnite has shown us that
different actors will come in to play
different roles
like troy baker he only just became the
voice of jonesy
last season can you hear me
hear me over time in save the world
ramirez assumed the leadership role she
was always seen at the front
leading by example front and center when
action was needed
but she was also very calm in her
actions but i know this isn't a story
about save the world
although i have to admit i do hope one
day the stories cross over
because of those v bucks we all use
they're from dr vindermann
and yet three years later we still don't
see him in battle royale
i'm getting sidetracked like always
let's realign this and look at ramirez
in
vr
battle royale island began as a humble
place a simple loop in time and space
not hurting anyone we originally guessed
this was a simulation to prepare
troops in the save the world universe
for battle against the husks
for this reason we only saw a handful of
combatants
because basically this was a video game
even at this extremely early point
two characters were viewed above all the
rest
we now know jonesy is one of them
jumping into the zero point and leaving
multiple versions of himself
in the loop but the second was unnoticed
by many of us
ramirez she was with him every step of
the way
from that first jump out of the battle
bus to this very moment
here's a bunch of times we've seen her
alongside jonesy over the years
let's go back to 2017. remember the
first encounters of fort nightmares
jonesy and ramirez were the first
characters to receive a must-have skin
in the store back when 50-50 matches
were announced
john z fronted one team and ramirez led
the other
she was even the first to be buggy
bombed when that item was released
and oh i like this one and guess who
brought in the minigun into fortnite
it's ramirez and that damn beautiful
bright bomber skin
a weapon i missed to this day the guided
missile the first target of that
was ramirez look i could go on and on
ramirez has been just as much a big part
of fortnite as
jonesy it's back in chapter one season
three that i'm most interested in her
actions
because the very first time we see
anyone outside the loop coming to the
world
it's via space travel and three more
figures
and once again you know what i'm gonna
say these characters are either johnsy
or ramirez and we all know how space
travel impacted the island
in the end
oh
chapter one season four who led the team
which found the meteor
ramirez okay i'll stop with all these
references now but there's loads over
the last three years
just know she's always been here and
other than jonesy ramirez has the most
variations in this loop see for yourself
open up your locker you will be shooketh
how many times you see a version of
ramirez
so let's stack up our evidence we have
three things to note
ramirez has been set up as the leader of
the fortnight save the world game mode
ramirez and the woman on the phone have
a very similar voice
building sentences in a very similar way
and thirdly
ramirez has been in the loop just as
long as johnsy
next piece of evidence let's break down
one of her story beats
back in season five of chapter one
worlds collide
remember this season damn it was good
when drift arrived on the island we had
this awesome weekly loading screen
update
which demonstrated how he integrated
himself in the island going from fear
and trepidation
into happiness and solidarity now look
at these images again
and look at all the characters who are
with him in all these screens
almost every time they are either johnsy
or ramirez
in particular it's the bright bomber
snapshot of ramirez
who is coming increasingly close to
drift
maybe it's a natural bond or maybe it's
a way to understand the powers he
brought to the island
as he was the very first living thing to
be brought through realities
to this place although we still think it
was accidental
what strikes me the most about this is
that drift's story ended
and seasons upon seasons went by without
mentioning him
but something happened on the final day
of the original island
we all said thank you to the bus driver
one last time and received this
loading screen last stop a total of five
seasons came and went
and drift was never even mentioned but
he came back for this one image
and look who he's paired with again
another bright bomber well technically a
beach bomber but you know what i mean
now take a second to look around this
image every other skin here that is
saying goodbye to the island
is either a jonesy snapshot or a ramirez
snapshot
all of them i get the feeling they knew
this wasn't the last stop
after two years it became clear to see
both ramirez and jonesy
are working together yet she doesn't get
the same
air time as johnsy
when chapter 2 arrived we started to see
less and less of ramirez
yet more and more joneses appeared this
made me think about how real jobs and
career paths work
and how some people are promoted when
others are not
this would explain why modern day loops
of ramirez are hard to find
but joneses keep rolling up loop after
loop
after loop let's change this up a little
bit during my research i also looked at
the bridge
this mysterious place jonzi uses to gain
access to our zero point
the importance of dark matter here is
integral
science tells us whether true or not
that's for you to decide
that dark matter creates a vacuum which
at a zero point
could create time altering effects and
now look at the energy plates used to
create this effect
these slabs look awfully like kevin the
cube's unknown energy
stick with me here i have a point i
promise remember when kevin was created
it was back in season five of chapter
one and look who was the first person to
touch the dark matter cube
and unleash the dark series of
characters it was ramirez
she discovered the power of this cube
ramirez is far more important to the
story than we ever
realized maybe this was the reason why
she was put in charge of others entering
the loop
and maybe she is the one who can tell us
more about the seven i do not draw the
attention of the seven
jones right there so that's my theory
i believe ramirez is the head of i o
the imagined order and therefore
jonesy's boss
what do you think if you can add more to
the law please let me know in the
comments below
and if you disagree that's cool but
remember to tell me why
if i'm wrong who's your money on who is
the leader of the imagined order
this episode of fortnite law was brought
to you by these awesome people who use
my code in the store
and sent me a dm on twitter like usual
i'm about a week behind on shout outs
but rest assured i will reply to you as
soon as i can
thank you so much i really appreciate it
i'm adam from playstation grenade
i'll see you next time
[Music]